David Boder: [In English] Paris, ah, August 12, 1946 at the headquarters of the American Joint Distribution Committee. The interviewee is David Lea with tattoo number 120930 of Auschwitz.
David Boder: [In German] Äh...Also Herr Lea, wollen Sie mir sagen, wo sind sie geboren?
David Lea: In Saloniki.
David Boder: Sie sind geboren in?
David Boder: In Saloniki.
David Lea: Griechenland [Unterbricht]
David Boder: In Griechenland. Und, äh, was für ein Staatsangehöriger sind sie? I mean, äh, von welchem Lande sind sie ein Staatsangehöriger? Äh, ich meine, äh, sind sie ein Grieche oder sind sie ein Spanier, oder was sind sie?
David Lea: Grieche.
David Boder: Sie sind Grieche, all right. Und sie sind in Saloniki geboren?
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Nun erzählen sie mich, äh, was hat dort passiert, wenn der Krieg angefangen hat?
David Lea: Ich hab gemacht Soldat in Militär, nachher Krieggefang in Krebv. [?] Nachher...
David Boder: Sie waren ein Soldat für wen? Für die Griechen? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Für die Griechen?
David Lea: Nach Albanien.
David Boder: Nach Albania [verwendet die englische Aussprache]
David Lea: Albania [verwendet nun ebenfalls die englische Aussprache]
David Boder: Und mit wem haben sie ge..., gegen wen haben sie gekämpft?
David Lea: Gegen Italia.
David Boder: Sie haben gekämpft gegen die...?
David Lea: Ich habe gekämpft [gleichzeitig mit Interviewer]...Krieg gegen Italia.
David Boder: Gegen die Italia.
David Lea: Ja.
David Boder: Nun und dann...
David Lea: Nun [unterbricht] und nachher kommen die Deutschen am, äh, sechsten April, sechsten Mai, April kommen nach Kreta. Nachher zweiundvierzig Tage gefangen mit den Deutschen nach Kreta.
David Boder: Ja
David Lea: Dann nachher drei Monate Kriegefangen.
David Lea: Komm nach Hause. Nachher sechs Monat...
David Boder: Wo sind sie nach Hause gekommen? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: In Saloniki...[Geräusch im Hintergrund] nach Saloniki.
David Boder: Im Haus dann nach Saloniki?
David Lea: Ja, jawohl, in Saloniki. Dann nachher deportieren Auschwitz.
David Boder: Wie lange haben sie gelebt in Saloniki?
David Lea: Gelebt in Saloniki?
David Boder: Nachdem sie nach Hause gekommen sind. Ja, bevor sie deportiert sind.
David Lea: Fünf Monat.
David Boder: Sie haben in Saloniki fünf Monate gelebt.
David Lea: Fünf Monat, jawohl.
David Boder: Wer waren denn in Saloniki, die Italiener oder die Deutschen?
David Lea: Die Deutsch, auch die Italiener.
David Boder: Die Italiener und auch die Deutschen?
David Lea: Die Deutschen, aber zusammen mit Italiener.
David Boder: Und dann, wieso hat man sie deportiert?
David Lea: Weil ich jüdisch.
David Boder: Aha, wie haben die bekannt gemacht, dass die Juden kommen sollen, oder was?
David Lea: Die Deutsch hat gemacht ein Ghetto.
David Boder: Oh.
David Lea: Hat gesproche in die jüdisch, jede Jüdisch von Griechenland wird fahren nach Polonia, nach Krakau, Arbeit. Wird gegeben Arbeit gut, Essen gut. Und sind sie griechisch, kann nicht vorstellen, wann, ich, äh, sprechen deutsch stimmt. Wird fahren zusammen mit der Familie.
David Boder: Sie sind mit ihrer Familie?
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Man hat die ganze Familie genommen.
David Lea: Hat ganze Familie genommen. [gleichzeitig] Mein...
David Boder: Von wo? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Von Saloniki. Mein Familie ist 37 Mann. Nur ich blieb, 36 Mann im Krematorium von Auschwitz. Brände in neun, äh, zwei- äh kleine Völkchen.
David Boder: Also, warten Sie mal. Sie sagen, da waren 37 Personen in ihrer Familie. Welche waren das?
David Lea: Mutter...
David Boder: Ihr Vater. [gleichzeitig]
David Lea: Vater, Mutter, Bruder [ständige Hintergrundgeräusche]
David Boder: Wie viel Brüder? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Drei Brüder mit zwei Bruder.
David Boder: Drei Brüder mit...?
David Lea: Mit zwei Bruder...Drei Brüder.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Zwei Fräulein noch dazu.
David Boder: Was?
David Lea: Zwei Fräulein.
David Boder: Zwei, äh, zwei Mädchens .
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Yes.
David Lea: Mein Mutter, mein Vater, mein Mutter von mein Vater, mein Mutter von meiner Ma und Cousin.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Alle zusammen.
David Boder: Hat man sie alle zusammen arretiert? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Also, alle zusammen 2. April. In neun Mai...
David Boder: Warten sie, man hat sie am 2. April arretiert und dann, wie hat man sie weggeschickt? [unterbricht]
David Lea: äh, weggeschickt, äh,..., in Transport.
David Boder: Ja, was für ein kind, äh, was für ein Transport war das?
David Lea: In Transport kein Wasser, kein Essen hat gemacht dort, kein hat gemacht die Deutschen bei uns.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Neun Tage in Transport, zugesperrt die Tür, die Fräulein also kaputt, halbe Transport vor kommen in Auschwitz, kaputt, tot....
David Boder: Oh, in, in...[unterbricht]
David Lea: . . . kein Brot, kein Brot in die Wagon. [spricht trotzdem weiter]
David Boder: Ja, und sie sind gestorben in...
David Lea: . . . sind gestorben in Wagon, die halbe Transport.
David Boder: Ja. Hat man nicht jeden Tag los gemacht, die...
David Lea: die Wagon?
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Jeden Tag. Nur, man hat gesagt, dort die SS ein bisschen Wasser äh macht kaputt. Die SS...du kann nicht waschen, äh, kaputt mache alle Jüdisch in die Wagon.
David Lea: Kommen...[Geräusch im Hintergrund] im Mai 43 nach Auschwitz. Die selbe Tage haben zwei danach getrennt, [unverständlich], 36 Mann. Nur...
David Boder: Was heißt man hat sie getrennt? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: In Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja, warum hat man sie nicht genommen?
David Lea: Warum – warum, ich nicht Nummer von 25 Jahre
David Boder: Oh, waren alle die übrigen älter von 25 Jahren?
David Lea: Jawohl, 25 Jahre alt bis 30 Jahre.
David Boder: Aha. 25 Jahre mit 30 Jahren hat gepasst.
David Lea: 25 Jahre [gleichzeitig]...Ja in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja, und die anderen?
David Lea: Die Anderen, die brennen.
David Boder: Was haben sie gesehen? Haben sie gesehen, wie man...
David Lea: Ich kam zusammen, keine Vorstellung hat gemacht die Deutsch, nur hat gemacht die Selektion. Die junge, bis 7 und 13, bis 20 Jahre, bis 30 Jahre [verbessert sich] und die anderen, sagen Deutsch, gehen zu Auto, die Mutter und die Vater, nachher kommt nach Revier.Als Revier bezeichnete man die Krankenstation in den Konzentrationslagern.1
David Boder: Oh. Man hat sie in Autos weg?
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Autos weg. Deutsche gesagt, welche krank, die Mutter die Vater, gute Esser nicht, gehen nach Revier. Nachher zwei Tage uns hat gesagt die SS, wo ist mein Familie. [Unverständlich] sage, noch drei vier Tage und sie kaputt. Nachher ein Monat, können sie vorstellen, mein Familie, ganze Familie von jüdisch nach Krematorium. Ich, äh, bin 44 Novem....
David Boder: Ja, äh. Nehmen sie die Hand runter.
David Lea: Ja, 44 Novembre,verwendet die französische Aussprache.2 ich bin in Auschwitz, in Lager Auschwitz. Hat gebrennet sechs, äh, Moment...
David Boder: [In English] He’s writing down the number. All right. [Pause]
David Boder: [In German] Six hunderttausend.
David Lea: In Novembre.
David Boder: In ein Monat?
David Lea: Moment, In Novembre.
David Boder: Ja
David Lea: Hat gebrennet die Deutsch, hat gemachet Unsinn. Die Kommando, Sonderkommando, arbeitendes Sonderkommando Krematorium. In sieben...
David Boder: Haben sie im Krematorium gearbeitet? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Ja in Bayern. In siebenundzwanzig Tage hat gebrennet sechs, sechzig, hunderttausend jüdisch ungarisch.
David Boder: 60.000 ungarische Juden.
David Lea: Ja...
David Boder: Haben sie im Krematorium gearbeitet? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Jawohl. [gleichzeitig] Jawohl, ich arbeite Krematorium. Ich dieselbe hab gebrennet. Sechs und tausend, äh, sechzig, äh...
David Boder: Sechshundertausend.
David Lea: Sechshundertausend jüdisch hat gebrennt bis zwa, zwa-, äh, bis siebenundzwanzig Tage. Nach Tage, jeden Tag hat gebrennt die Krematorium von, äh, Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Nachher komm die Russisch. 18 April. 18 Junai von Radom zu Lager Ausschwitz, die Russisch komm 28 Junai.Er meint hier wohl eher Januar als Juni. Das Lager Auschwitz wurde am 27. Januar 1945 von der russischen Armee befreit.3 Nachher ich fahre Buchenwald. Special...[Geräusche im Hintergrund]
David Boder: Wann waren sie in Buchenwald?
David Lea: In Buchenwald ich hab gemacht drei Monat, zwei waren Dauchau, ein Woche lang Fürth, nachher kommen 29 April die amerikanisch Truppe nach Dachau auf Befehl.
David Boder: Aha, ja. Und haben sie befreit.
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Also, sie sagen, dass sie haben gearbeitet in Auschwitz im Krematorium?
David Lea: Ja, Ja, Jawohl.
David Boder: Äh...
David Lea: Sonderkommando.
David Boder: Im Sonderkommando. Also beschreiben sie, wie, was ist im Krematorium zugegangen? Was war das Krematorium? [Pause] Oh. [Pause]
David Boder: [In English] He’s lighting a cigarette. He wanted to roll one, but I offered him an American cigarette and light my own.
David Boder: [In German] Also sagen sie, sie haben gearbeitet im Krematorium. Wollen sie mir beschreiben, wie hat man im Krematorium gearbeitet und wie hat das Krematorium ausgesehen?
David Lea: In, also wie man hat gearbeitet...? [zögert]
David Boder: Ja, also wie hat man, wie hat das Krematorium ausgesehen?
David Lea: Jawohl, ja. Kommt Transporte von jedem...kommt Transporte von ganz Europa jüdische...
David Boder: Ein bisschen näher. [unterbricht]
David Lea: Kommt Transporte von ganz Europa jüdische. Junge von zwei Monat, von fünf Jahre, von sieben Jahre, von zehn Jahre, von achtzehn Jahre. Mensch von 80 Jahre, 90 Jahre bleibt dort. Kommt nach, äh, Krematorium. Ist ein großes Saale. Schreibe Franzose äh Deutsch. Mein, äh, – sage, ein AfficheBenutzt den französischen Begriff für Aushang.4 in Krematorium sage, alles ausziehen. Mache bade. Die Menschen machen bade. Ich die, äh, ich gesund, wann ich...wann ich bade, ich gesund. Dinge, die ich kann nicht verstehen, was bestimmt spreche, alles ausziehen, zusammen, die Männer mit die Fräulein zusammen, die Frauen von 80 Jahre, die Mädchen von 20 Jahre, alle zusammen. Äh, wann die zusammen alles, bekommen die Seife und die – was ist diese...
David Boder: Handtuch.
David Lea: Handtuch, Seife. Ein SS von anderes Zimmer, gucke, alles schon, alles schon er-, erledigt, alles schon fertig. Alles schon ist aus. Hat gemacht auf die Luminette und die Gas. in zwei Minut, ein bis zwei Minut, kaputt zwei, dreitausend Mann.
David Boder: Sind sie richtig gestorben?
David Lea: Richtig gestorben. Nachher, die klein Junge, zwei, äh, vier Jahre, drei Jahre. Nur bekommen...äh...äh hier...[scheint auf seine Nase zu zeigen]Blut, äh, Blut, Bluten.
David Boder: Nasebluten.
David Lea: Nase-, Nasebluten von, von äh Gift. Nur die Klein hat geschreiet. Mama, Mama, Mama. Aber die Mutter nachher, nach ein, äh, ein Minut die Mutter war fertig, die ganze Familie. Nachher kommen Unsinn. Ich Ventilateur,Benutzt den französischen Begriff.5 Ventilateur.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Hat gemacht auch Unsinn, dieselbe, die Sonderkommando, die Ventilateur.
David Lea: Die Gas weg...Raus.
David Boder: Raus, ja.
David Lea: (undeutlich)
David Boder: Ja, ja.
David Lea: Bekommen Töne.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Schmeißen die Tot in die WagonnetBenutzt den französischen Begriff.6...
David Boder: Yes.
David Lea: und nachher in die Krematorium.
David Boder: Also, ja. Was war die Krematorium? Ein Ofen? [Pause] Was war es? Ein Ofen, äh.. ein...?
David Lea: Ko-, Ko-, Kohle.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Kohl, Kohl..
David Boder: Äh, yes. War es ein Ofen oder war es ein...?
David Lea: Nicht. Äh, Krematorium, Krematorium...[unterbricht] und die...
David Boder: Ja, ja. Wie viel Menschen auf einmal hat man verbrennen können? [unterbricht]
David Lea: Wann ich, äh, mit Transport kommen jeden Tag zehn Transport von 20 bis 40 Tausend Mann. Acht Mann ein Krematorium, zwanzig Minuten gebrennet. Nach die Tage jeden Tag Gebrenne gemacht in Krematorium. Jeden Tag, nach Sabbat, jeden Tag Gebrenne in Krematorium. In Krematorium war Arbeit ungefähr 5, äh, 1.500 Mann. 500 Mann jede Stunde, jede acht Stunde Arbeit. Nachher dann tauschen, andere 500 Mann. Und die arbeiten in Sonderkommando, gut gegessen.
David Boder: Hat man ihnen gut zu Essen gegeben?
David Lea: Ja, jawohl. Nachher die 1.500 Mann arbeite nur drei Monat. Denn nachher die SS hat gemacht kaputt, mit, äh, die ungef. die 1500 Mann.
David Boder: Wie haben sie sie kaputt gemacht?
David Lea: Warum—Nichts wolle sprechen, was sie da machen in Krematorium.
David Boder: Aber wie haben sie sie kaputt gemacht. Auch im Krematorium?
David Lea: Auch im Krematorium. Und die SS macht kaputt in Krematorium dieselbe, die, die, äh, Sonderkommando. Nachher drei Monat dabei, nachher in Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Gebrennt dieselbe. Ich nicht gebrennt, wann kommen die Russisch.
David Boder: Aha.
David Lea: Wenn mein Kommando, die Sonderkommando, 1500 Mann nicht gebrennet, dann kommen die Russisch. Und die Deutschen, keine Zeit, keine Zeit. Wenn ich hab Zeit, och, hundert gebrennet.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: In, äh, 43...die Krematorium, vier, vier...[Hintergrundgeräusch]...Nummer Krematorium vier, die Griechisch von Saloniki, Athen hat gemachet ein Bomb. Bombe macht kaputt.
David Boder: Wer hat gemacht?
David Lea: Die Griechisch von Athen. In, äh, 34.
David Boder: In, äh, ähm 44.
David Lea: 44.
David Boder: Waren es jüdische Griechen?
David Lea: Jüdische Griechisch, zusammen mit den Polacken.
David Boder: Zusammen mit den Polacken haben sowas getan.
David Lea: Ja. Hat...
David Boder: Aufgerissen.
David Lea: Aufgerissen, ja, hat Munition in Krematorium vier. Griechische von Athena und Polack jüdisch von Ghetto von Warschaua.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Hat gemacht kaputt Krematorium vier.
David Boder: Wo, in, äh, Auschwitz?
David Lea: Nein, in Birkenau.
David Boder: In Birkenau. Genau Auschwitz und Birkenau. Ähm, wie haben sie das Krematorium kaputt gemacht?
David Lea: Die jüdisch – äh, griechisch und jüdisch Polack.
David Boder: Aha und was hat man denen getan?
David Boder: Äh, sind sie leben geblieben die Menschen?
David Lea: Alles kaputt, drin in Krematorium.
David Boder: Die Menschen, die drin waren?
David Lea: . . . die auch. Die Menschen, die drin waren. [Unterbricht] Wann die, die, äh, Mensch ist raus [unverständlich] ist mit die Gewehrmaschin. Die SS sage, wenn ich Unsinn mache in Krematorium, ist unser kaputt. Alles zerstört, drinnen mit die Mensch, die jüdische Polack und die jüdische von Griechenland. Nachher zwei Minut...kaputt
David Boder: Haben sie das selbst gesehen?
David Lea: Ich hab gesehen nicht, wann ich bin im Revier. [Hintergrundgeräusch]
David Boder: Was?
David Lea: Ich bin krank.
David Boder: Oh sie waren krank und sie waren im Revier.
David Lea: [unverständlich, da gleichzeitig mit Interviewer]...war in Revier, nicht gesehen, aber doch Bum.
David Boder: Sie haben gehört, wie es passiert ist.
David Lea: Alles ja. [unterbricht]
David Boder: Und nachdem man die Krematorien aufgerissen hat, hat man noch Leute verbrannt nachdem?
David Lea: Nicht.
David Boder: Nein, man hat keinerlei...
David Lea: Kein. [gleichzeitig]
David Boder: Keinerlei.
David Lea: Äh, vor zwei Tage evakuiert die Lager von Birkenau, SS hat gemacht kaputt, alles Krematorium.
David Boder: Alles selbst kaputt gemacht.
David Lea: Von zwei Tage evakuiert die Lager von Birkenau. 18 April, evakuiert bei uns Lager. 16 nein 18, äh, 18...
David Boder: Nein, nein, nein, nehmen sie die Hand runter. [Unterbricht] Ja.
David Lea: 18 Junai,Siehe oben. Auch hier meint er wohl Januar und nicht Juni.7 im April, 18 Junai 45 evakuiert die Lager Auschwitz. 16 Junai 45, die Deutsch hat gemacht kaputt die Krematorien. Sechs Krematorien hat gemacht kaputt die Deutsch.
David Boder: Sie selbst? Und wie viel haben die Griechen kaputt gemacht?
David Lea: Die Griechen kaputt und auch die Polack kaputt.
David Boder: Ja, aber wieviel Krematorien haben die Griechen...
David Lea: Ein Krematorium. [unterbricht] Ein Krematorium. Ein Krematorium vier. Dieselbe, die jüdische Polack hat gemacht die Krematorium vier kaputt.
David Boder: Aha, und den Rest haben die SS kaputt gemacht.
David Lea: SS kaputt gemacht.
David Boder: Nun, also wo sind sie gegangen nachdem, äh, wer hat sie befreit, die Russen oder die Amerikaner?
David Lea: Amerikanisch. 29 April 45.
David Boder: Von welchem Lager?
David Lea: Von Dachau.
David Boder: Von Dachau. Äh, war in Dachau auch ein Krematorium?
David Lea: In Dachau Krematorium, 44 hat gemacht nur ein Krematorium. Warum hat gemacht. In Dachau ist verboten für die jüdisch.
David Boder: Was?
David Lea: In Dachau ist verboten...
David Boder: In Dachau war’s verboten von jüdischer Rang. Keine Juden in Dachau.
David Lea: Ja. Keine Juden, kein Krematorium.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Nachher. 5, äh, 5, äh 45 komme ich, hat gemachet noch ein Krematorium. Für alles, für die jüdische, für die Arier. Nachher in April, in 29 April...
David Boder: Ja. Sagen sie Haben sie in irgendwelch einem Lager Zigeuner gesehen?
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Erzählen sie mir von den Zigeunern.
David Lea: In Lager, in Lager von Birkenau.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Hat gesehen Zigeuner—sieben, acht tausend Mann Zigeuner, nicht jüdisch, zusammen mit die Kinder, mit die alles. Gut gegessen, drei, fünf, sieben Monat. Nachher, ein Nacht, eine Stunde, einer von Früh hat gemacht die Deutsche antreten hat ganze Zigeunerlager.
David Lea: Hat ganze Zigeunerlager, nachher zwei Stunde acht neun Mann, acht neun Tausend Mann zusammen mit die Kinderchen kaputt, alles Zigeuner. Und nachher man in Lager Birkenau nicht gucken mehr Zigeuner.
David Boder: Also man hat alle Zigeuner tot gemacht.
David Lea: Alle tot.
David Boder: Hat man sie auch durch die Gaskammern geschickt?
David Lea: Alles, alle durch die Gas.
David Boder: Mh. Warum hat man das getan?
David Lea: Ich weiß nicht warum.
David Boder: Sie wissen nicht warum
David Lea: Jawohl
David Boder: Äh. Und wer hat nachher im Block gewohnt, wo die Zigeuner gewohnt haben?
David Lea: Ja. In Block Zigeuners gewohnt. Oder Block für Zigeuner, nur Zigeuner. Warum ist—Zigeuner bleibt, warum nicht Arier, kein SS zusammen ziehen lassen.
David Boder: Aber wenn man alle Zigeuner tot, äh, wenn man alle Zigeuner getötet hat, wer hat nachher im Block gelebt?
David Lea: Die Block ist aus.
David Boder: Der Block ist...
David Lea: Gesperrt. [unterbricht]
David Boder: Der Block ist gesperrt gewesen.
David Lea: Gesperrt.
David Boder: Ja...Und was tun sie jetzt Herr Lea?
David Lea: Ich arbeite in Komitee [unverständlich, Hintergrundgeräusch].
David Boder: Sie arbeiten im Komitee in [unverständlich].
David Lea: Ich hab keine Familie.
David Boder: Was?
David Lea: Keine Familie.
David Boder: Sie haben keine Familie.
David Lea: 36 Mann—kaputt.
David Boder: Aha, und äh, was wollen sie tun nachher? Wie sind sie nach Frankreich gekommen?
David Lea: Warum in Griechenland? Ich hab...
David Boder: Wie sind sie gekommen? [Unterbricht] Von—wie alt sind sie? Wie alt sind sie?
David Lea: Ich bin, wie alt bin ich?.... 28.
David Boder: Sie sind 28 Jahre alt. Allright. Und jetzt stehen sie mit dem Joint?
David Lea: Jawohl.
David Boder: Haben sie Verwandte in Amerika?
David Lea: Kein.
David Boder: Keine. Haben sie Verwandte in Palästina?
David Boder: [In English] This concludes um, um Spool 41, of which half is Ms. Precker and the other one is Mr. Lea. After the machine stopped, he suggested that he has something more to tell.
David Boder: This is Spool number 42. Mr. David Lea continued.
David Boder: [In German] Mr. Lea sie sagten,....was wollten sie sagen von Auschwitz?
David Lea: Von Warschau.
David Boder: Oh. Sie sagten, sie waren in Warschau. Wieso sind sie nach Warschau gekommen?
David Lea: Ich ging nach Warschau von nach Birkenau sechs Septembre.Er verwendet den französischen Begriff.8 Jom Kippur.
David Boder: Ja. Wieso sind sie befreit von Birkenau gewesen?
David Lea: Von Birkenau Transport von die jüdisch nach Arbeit in Warschaua.
David Boder: Oh, die – wer hat sie genommen dort?
David Lea: Die SS.
David Boder: Die SS hat sie genommen von Birkenau nach Auschwitz, äh nach Warschau. Erzählen sie, was hat dort passiert. [Lea spricht ständig bestätigend dazwischen]
David Lea: Arbeit in Ghetto in die Hause von die jüdisch. Das ganze Ghetto ist, die Ghetto von Warschaua, [Hintergrundgeräusch] zweihundert Meter, so lange von Friedhof von Warschaua ist jüdisch. Ich nicht verstehe die Stadt, warum, ich nicht spreche Polack .
David Boder: Polnisch, ja.
David Lea: Die, die Leute deportiert Polack, wenn ich jetzt nach, äh, in Amerika, als Stadt, zwei- zweihundert, äh zweihundert Meter ist lange die Friedhof, von die jüdisch, nach mein Lager.
David Boder: Aha
David Lea: Arbeit...
David Boder: Warum hat man sie geschickt von Auschwitz nach Warschau? [unterbricht]
David Lea: Warum ich geschicket. Als junger, gesund Mensch. Arbeit.
David Boder: Wer—Wo haben sie sollen arbeiten?
David Lea: Arbeiten in die Stadt, mit die Pickel, mit die Pickel, mit die Scheffel [Schaufel]. Kein Essen, nur 150 Gramm Brot jeden Tag, Mittag ein Liter Wasser. So, Arbeit, äh, 40 Stunden.
David Boder: Mh. Also, was ist passiert?
David Lea: Ich nachher SS hat gesproche. [Pause]
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Jeder Jüdisch von Arbeit, in die Lager von die jüdisch, alles kaputt. Die Lager ist so lange, so weit, 50 Meter von Pawiak to Warschau.
David Lea: Arbeiten in die BunkiAnmerkung: Die Bedeutung von „Bunki“ ist nicht ganz klar. Offensichtlich sprechen sie über den „Bund“, die jüdische Widerstandsorganisation im Warschauer Ghetto bzw. den Allgemeinen Jüdischen Arbeiterbund.9, [unverständlich] dieselbe deutsch. Junge hat ganze Familie jüdisch mit die Kinderchen kaputt hat gemacht. Die Kampf mit die Deutsch von 39. Nachher SS mit zu vielleicht, komm rüber, bei uns in die Bunki. Weil jüdisch, wann sie suchen, wann sie suche Jüdisch in die Bunki. Ich zuviel jüdisch in die Bunki, nicht kaputt, also kaputt, äh, also nicht kaputt. Ich genommen hab Gewehrmaschine, ge- äh gestohlen.
David Boder: Was sind die Bunki? Was ist der Bund?
David Lea: Der Bunki ist jüdisch, Verband, noch machen Sabotage, die nachmachen Sabotage drinnen in die Ghetto. Und gucken in die Straße die Deutsch mach kaputt. Auf Arbeit, Arbeit acht, äh, neun Monat in, äh, Warschau.
David Boder: Ja.
David Lea: Nachher Lager von Warschaua evakuiert.
David Lea: In Lager von Warschau ist großer Transport, Jom Kippur, kommen in, äh, Warschaua, nur griechisch, jüdische Barack. Warum, Unsinn diese Barack griechisch, nicht verstehen Polack, verstehen England. Die Deutsch hat gesagt, welche nicht verstehen Polack, kommen in Warschaua. Hat gesagt, guter [unverständlich], gut [unverständlich]. Unsinn, die jüdische Barack gehen in Warschaua. Warum, die Deutsch Angst. Wenn ich arbeit in Warschaua und ich verstehen Polack, muss weg. Aber nur die jüdische Barack nicht verstehen Polack. Die Deutsch kein Angst bei uns. Nachher Jüdisch Barack kaputt, komm...Polack Jüdische. Polack Jüdische, ungarische Jüdische...Lithuan Jüdische...von Krakau Jüdische, von Ukrainisch Jüdische. 40 Stunden Arbeit die Tage, Deutschlager, nachher die Nacht Appell drei Stunden, Schuhe, keine Schuhe, keine Strümpfe, Schuhe von Holz...kein Handschuh, Arbeit einmal Schuhe, einmal Mantel...ein Mantel. Wann kommen in die, in die Platz von Arbeit, die Kapos, deutsch, sagen, ausziehe die Mantel. (Unsere/Unsinn) ausziehe die Mantel, hat gemacht ausziehen, was man hat gesagt. Warum, tot schlagen. Draußen kalt jede Tage, mit die Schaufel mit die Pickel, eine Stunde Arbeit, nachher kaputt.
David Boder: Was heißt kaputt?
David Lea: Von, äh,...von Kalt, kein Esse, kein...kein Esse, kein Vitamins, keine Schlafen, zu viel Läuse. Die...
David Boder: Läuse? [unterbricht]
David Lea: Läuse zu viel. Typhus in die Lager von Warschaua. Typhus jeden Tag 80, 90, 100 Mann kaputt. In Revier, kein Essen in Revier. Nun kommt die SS, die [unverständlich] SS, ein deutsch, sagen alle jüdisch kaputt. Mit die ein, was ist.... Macht kaputt.
David Boder: Mit was? Mit Einspritze?
David Lea: Ja, so [scheint es ihm zu zeigen]
David Boder: Mit Injection.
David Lea: Ja, Injection in Revier. In Lager von Warschaua, die Revier ist Block 7.
David Boder: [In English] He demonstrates by hand, he didn’t know the word. There were people that were killed by injection. No?
David Lea: In Lager von Warschaua die Revier ist Block 7 oder Block 8. Die Chef von Revier ist ein Deutsch. Schlecht die jüdische kaputt. [unverständlich] in die Krematorium, alles jüdisch, eh kaputt. Kein jüdisches nachhause mehr. Nachher weg in Lager Landsberg. Ist ob Bayern. Ich Arbeit in Landsberg. Die Lagerführer verstand mich von Birkenau. Die äh hat gearbeit in Sonderkommando. Eine Tag hat gesagt, kommen sie, arbeite in Friedhofkommando...
David Boder: In welchem Kommando?
David Lea: In Friedhofkommando nach Landsberg, Bayern. Ich hab dieselbe, mein Kommando, noch 15 Mann ich 16 Mann alles. 12000, 5, 1500 hundert 37 jüdisch in ein Monat Arbeit. Diese Lager...
David Boder: Wie haben sie die Nummer gewusst? Wie haben sie gezählt?[unterbricht]
David Lea: Das mache die [unverständlich]. ich zweihundert tot, 180 tot, die Lagerführung hat gemachet Report. Jetzt holte ich 50 Polack tot, 20 griechisch jüdisch tot, 10 ungarische, 10 Slowak, mache Report. In ein Monat Arbeit 12 tausend vier hundert 37 kaputt. Diese Friedhof, kein Maßstab, kann kein Mensch vorstellen, nur die 16 Mann, was arbeit.
David Boder: Wie haben sie Gräber gemacht? Für jeden ein separates Grab? [Unterbricht]
David Lea: Vierhundert Mann ein Loch. Dreihundert Mann ein Loch. Nachher hat gemacht tief zwei Meter 40 Zentimeter.
David Boder: Was?
David Lea: Zwei Meter 40 Zentimeter dick.
David Boder: Tief
David Lea: Tief. Kommen jeden Wagen, jeden Wagen 40 tot. Kommt zusammen die Wagen nach die Tot, die SS Unsinn die Jüdisch, wollte ein bisschen (undeutlich). Die SS nix hat gelassen. Hat gesehen Kamerad Arbeit in, mit die [unverständlich] hat gesagt, ist mein Bruder, mein Cousin. Ein bisschen gelesen. Kein bisschen gelesen...
David Boder: Kein bisschen was?
David Lea: Gelesen.
David Boder: Ah...
David Lea: Nix. Tot, tot die Mensch, die Bruder...
David Boder: Ah gebetet.
David Lea: Gelesen. Bracha
David Boder: Aha, zu machen Broche. No? Hat er...[wird unterbrochen]
David Lea: Die SS hat geschlagen tot. SS ein Tag hat der Kamerad, hat Kamerad bekommen für beten. Gegen die SS sagen, nimm mein Portion Brot sagen die SS...
David Boder: Warten Sie, Sie sagen...[unterbricht, Lea spricht jedoch weiter]
David Lea: . . . mein Kamerad sagen, diese, die Tot ist mein Bruder. Wollen ein bisschen gelesen. Die SS genommen die Pick und die Schaufel hauen die Kopf, zusammen mit die Bruder kaputt.
David Boder: Aha, um, a person has asked permission to pray over his brother who he had to bury. But he tells the SS killed him with the Shovel and buried them both. All right.
David Lea: Nachher, ein Tage. 400 tot, äh, 400. In jede Loch 400 tot, 300, 350. Nachher zusperre die tot mit die [unverständlich]. Die Lager dort hat gesagt, mache, kann man sagen, die Loch, damit man nicht versteht, warum tot diese Leut. Die Friedhof hat gemacht und ich in Bayern, in die Mitte.
David Boder: Wo ist das? In Warschau?
David Lea: Nicht in Warschau. In Landsberg, Bayern.
David Boder: In, in...?
David Lea: In Landsberg, Bayern.
David Boder: Bavaria?
David Lea: Bavaria.
David Boder: Ja
David Boder: Was für ein Lager war in Landsberg?
David Lea: In Landsberg ist, ganze Landsberg ist Endlager.
David Boder: Aha.
David Lea: Lager eins, Lager zwei, Lager drei, Lager vier, Lager fünf, Lager sechs, Lager sieben, Lager acht, Lager neun, Lager zehn, Lager elf. In die Lager vier, Lager sieben, Lager sieben, ist Lager nur Quarantäne
David Boder: Nur Quarantäne?
David Lea: Quarantäne macht kaputt die Jüdische mit die Injection. In die Lager eins ist die Ober, in Lager eins ist ein Lager, Arbeitslager. Die Name ist Tannberg. Die schlechte Mensch...
David Boder: Welcher Name? [unterbricht]
David Lea: Tannberg. Deutsch. Tannberg, Tannberg. Diese SS jetzt ist in Nürnberg. Ein Kamerad von mir, russisch-jüdisch. Die Name ist Kosakov. Gehen Prozess nach ..
David Boder: Nürnberg.
David Lea: Nürnberg. Gucken diesen. In die Prozess hat gesprochen die Kommandant von Tribunal amerikanisch. Diese, die schlechte Menschen und die Jüdisch hat gemacht 29, und dieselbe. Nachher ich weiß nicht, was ich hätt gemacht, mit diese SS. In Lager vier, ist dieselbe von Lager fünf, Lager sieben. Quarantäne. 27. April 44, 45. Die FDG. Chef SS von Revier.
David Boder: Was ist FDG?
David Lea: FDG ist Chef von Revier. SS. Unter die Déporté, Chef von die Revier SS sage, FDG, hat gebrennet. Die Leute, ist zu viel, ist zu viel kranke, hat gebrennet. Mensch Gesund. Mehr von 3000 Mann mit die Gas. Nachher, zwei Stunde kommen die Amerikanisch. Die Amerikanisch hat, äh..., hat gesagt, jeden Deutsch von Bayern, kommt gucke, was gemacht die Deutsch. Die Mensch gesund hat gebrennet, mit die Gas, mit die Flamme.
David Boder: Ja, ja.
David Lea: Ein Kamerad...
David Boder: Wie hat man sie gebrannt? Mit...[unterbricht]
David Lea: Mit die, äh, die Flamm.
David Boder: Mit Flame throwers?
David Lea: Jawohl, jawohl, jawohl.
David Boder: Gesunde Menschen hat er verbrannt mit, äh, Feuer-, äh, werfer.
David Lea: Warum getan. Die FDG hat gesehen die Amerikanisch ist nach, ist zwanzig Kilometer nach Bayern, daher hat gemacht kaputt die jüdisch. Nicht jüdisch, nicht vorstellen, warum ist zuviel krank, kein Essen. Bis März, bis April 45, bekommen in Lager vier nur 80 Gramm Brot jeden Tag. Kein, kein Margarine, kein Essen. Mittag ein Liter nur Wasser. So jeden Tage, 200, 300 Jüdisch kaputt. In zwei Monat war ganze Lager kaputt. Nachher zwei Monat trage andere Jüdisch von Lager fünf, von Lager drei, von Lager zwei, von Lager neun, von Lager elf, elf. Ist dieselbe, hat gesehn, hat gegucket. In Lager drei. Drei April 44. Jüdische, Lithuan, macht kaputt, die Jüdische krank, die Tot. Jüdische. Esse die.
David Boder: Mh?
David Lea: Die jüdische, die Jüdische...
David Boder: Haben gegessen...
David Lea: Haben gegessen, die tot Jüdische. Haben...
David Boder: Ja, in wel, in welch...[unterbricht]
David Lea: Ja, haben gegessen [gleichzeitig] In Lager drei. In Bayern. Bayern
David Boder: Äh,wo war das? In Dachau, in...
David Lea: Nicht. In Landsberg, Bayern. Lager drei.
David Boder: Aha. In Landsberg. Haben die Ju- äh die Menschen gegessen von den Menschen?
David Lea: Ja. Ich selbe hab gegucket.
David Boder: Ja, sie selbst haben gesehen.
David Lea: Ich selbe. In Lager drei.
David Boder: Ja, nun. Hat man den gar nichts gegessen gegeben?
David Lea: Gar nichts gegessen. Nachher die SS hat gesperrt die Lager, hat gesagt, kein Dinner.
David Boder: All right. Sagen sie das...Können sie dasselbe in Griechisch sagen? In Griechisch? Können sie griechisch sprechen?
David Lea: Ja, ein wenig.
David Boder: Sagen sie mir dasselbe in Griechisch.
David Lea: Sprechen sie nicht spanisch. Warum nicht spanisch?
David Boder: [In Spanish] ¿Usted habla español?
David Lea: Claro que hablo español.
David Boder: Oh! ¿Por qué no me dijo? Bueno, dígame otra vez del caso de cuando...del canibalismo
David Lea: ¿En español?
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Señores y señoras. Yo me topé con dos soldados, con tres soldados, en el campo de Landsberg, campo 3, en Baviera. Después de 15 a 20 días que no teníamos nada de comida, nosotros los deportados, había muchos muertos, tomamos una tarde a las 10 y un cuarto de una hora de la tarde, tomamos los cuchillos y curtimos a nuestros compañeros judíos que ya estaban muertos. Y comimos la carne suya.
David Boder: ¿Usted también?
David Lea: Claro. Me acuerdo, el 3 de febrero del 45. En todo el campo, estábamos judíos españole de [ininteligible] y los restantes eran judíos de [ininteligible], de Varsovia, de Lituana, de Bélgica, de [ininteligible], de Italia y de otras ciudades que estaban ocupadas por las bárbaras armadas enemigas de la Europa.
David Boder: ¿Y?
David Lea: Nosotros sufrimos tanto tiempo, mucho. Tres años en el campo. Después que la comida era muy poca, no nos alcanzaba y trabajábamos 14 horas al día.
David Boder: Hable más despacio. ¿En qué trabajaban ustedes?
David Lea: Nosotros trabajábamos en hacer fortificaciones.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Con la pala y la [ininteligible]. Después que laborábamos [ininteligible] como podíamos trabajar, nos maltrataban con los palos y [ininteligible] a muerte.
David Lea: En un transporte que vino de Varsovia, en 1944, cuando los rusos se aproximaban a Varsovia. El más grande transporte y el más grande desastre de la historia judía fue de Varsovia que nos deportaron con trenes 18 días. En trenes de animales, acerrados noche y día, guardados por cuatro bárbaros de las SS con las metralletas, sin agua, sin nada de comida, el sol tanto...Y se murieron más de 8000 personas. Éramos 8726 personas y tornamos al campo de [ininteligible] 725 personas. Los 8000 fueron matados o por el hambre, o por los SS, o por la sequía.
David Boder: Bueno, ¿ese transporte iba de dónde?
David Lea: Ese transporte venía de Varsovia...
David Boder: De Varsovia a...
David Lea: A Dachau. Los rusos se acercaban de Varsovia y los alemanes nos querían...nos...necesitaban algo de nosotros para trabajar y tomar al interior de Alemania. No nos querían matar y para eso nos encerraron en unos vagones, a 120 personas en un vagón de animales.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Cerrados noche y día, sin un...
David Boder: ¿Por qué lo llama “vagón de animales”? ¿No era un vagón de carga?
David Lea: No. No disponían. Y ellos no disponían, les estaba...era...era prohibido...era prohibido para los judíos.
David Boder: Ajá.
David Lea: Estábamos ahí, maltratados por unas bestias y nosotros levantábamos las manos a Dios [ininteligible] que no podemos más sufrir. Mismo que queríamos [ininteligible] de pillar, todos al lado. El SS nos decía “¿quién quiere pillar?”, mas nosotros ya veíamos que otros camaradas iban a pillar, iban a facer lo que sea...
David Boder: Ajá. En el carro.
David Lea: En el carro. Venía el SS y con la metralleta lo mataba y nosotros éramos [ininteligible] nos pillar en los pantalones...eh...todo. Y a veces, queríamos salir de cuerpo, salíamos en la mano y lo arrojábamos por un buraco que habíamos fecho en el vagón
David Boder: Esto fue en el mes de...
David Lea: Junio y julio del 44
David Boder: Junio y julio...
David Lea: Sí. Junio y julio, porque no me puedo acordar exactamente
David Boder: Sí. No es importante.
David Lea: porque habíamos perdido la moral, cual la familia, cual las finanzas y cual no tenemos fuerza. Todos los judíos que tornaron de los campos de concentración de Alemania puede ser que estemos buenos de cuerpo, de facha, mas en el interior no estamos buenos. Estamos todos [ininteligible].
David Boder: ¿Por qué?
David Lea: Porque el trabajo era mucho, la poca comida, la leña que nos daban, el frío y mucho. Estamos todos jalados en los pulmones, quien con reumatismo, quien con asma, quien los pulmones y...la más parte tienen...pierden...pierden su moral. Yo estoy hablando, un judío griego, [ininteligible] separadito. Si me acuerdo más...podíamos [ininteligible] hablar más seguido, no me estoy acordando.
David Lea: La desgracia que hubo al 44 en el campo de Birkenau, más o menos no podía hablar porque no soy bueno en alemán...no me explico, mas en seguida lo voy a hablar en español. En el 44, a la fin del 44, en noviembre, en el campo de Birkenau, en septiembre, octubre o noviembre, 600.000 hungareses judíos vinieron en Birkenau. Después que los crematorios no daban abasto para quemar a los judíos, los SS ordenaron 3000 hombres que hagan unos pozos.
David Boder: ¿Cómo dijo?
David Lea: Pozos, pozos. [El entrevistado dice algo en otro idioma para hacerse entender].
David Boder: Ah...agujas...
David Lea: Sí. Agujas.
David Boder: Agujeros
David Lea: Sí. Y quemaron en 27 días 600.000 judíos vivos. Los vimos nosotros, nosotros porque yo laboraba [ininteligible] comando al crematorio, y los vía por del frente, los quemaron vivos con leña y bencina. Los transportes que venían, había veces
David Boder: Los quemaban en agujeros, no en los...
David Lea: No los quemaron...No los quemaron en los hornos porque no tenían tiempo.
David Boder: Sí. No los pasaron en el chambre...cámara de gas
David Lea: No. No los pasaron en la cámara de gas porque no tenían tiempo los alemanes.
David Boder: ¿Entonces qué?
David Lea: Los quemaron en los...en los pozos que hicimos nosotros, con leña y con essence
David Boder: ¿Con qué?
David Lea: Con essence, bencina.
David Boder: Bencina.
David Lea: Bencina.
David Boder: Bueno. ¿Les mataron anteriormente o qué?
David Lea: Los quemaron vivos. No los mataron, los quemaron vivos.
David Boder: ¿Los quemaron vivos?
David Lea: Vivos. Seiscientos mil hungareses judíos, al noviembre o al septiembre. No me acuerdo exactamente la data y el día, mas me acuerdo que yo vide esto [ininteligible]
David Boder: ¿Cómo?
David Lea: [ininteligible] lo vi esto como si la [ininteligible] fuera mía.
David Boder: Bueno.
David Lea: Los transportes que venían ahí estaban guardados por miles de SS y en todo el convoy había como 20 a 25 o 50 [ininteligible]. Y en el último que vi había una Jeep alemana, decían que era la Croix Rouge. Y los judíos, cuando les...los metían al convoy, les decían que los iban a ir al hospital y los judíos lo creían porque veían que estaban acompañados por el [ininteligible]
David Boder: ¿El [ininteligible] tenía qué? ¿Una cruz roja?
David Lea: El [ininteligible] tenía la Croix Rouge y tenía...
David Boder: ¿Qué es “Croix Rouge”?
David Lea: La Cruz Roja
David Boder: ¿La Cruz Roja?
David Lea: Sí. Tenía en la [ininteligible], tenía una bandera blanca con la Cruz Roja y decía que lo vamos a llevar al hospital a mirar, y lo vamos a llevar [ininteligible]. Después, allí...adentro de allí abría los gases.
David Boder: Ajá.
David Lea: Mas [ininteligible] sabía de eso, el transporte [ininteligible]. Mesmo nosotros mismos [ininteligible]. Mas después de un mes, dos meses, tres meses que laboré al crematorio, ya supimos que contiene. El gas lo traen con la Cruz Roja. Con el [ininteligible], con la coche de la Cruz Roja.
David Boder: De la Cruz Roja. Sí.
David Lea: De la Cruz Roja. Esto como estoy explicando...yo lo estoy explicando que [ininteligible] si no lo puedo explicar, caros hermanos [ininteligible] y no vas a poder sentir. Es la más desgracia, la más grande que hubo en el crematorio. [ininteligible] nuestros hermanos. Seis millones de judíos murieron en los campos, cuales maltratados, cuales de hambre, cuales [ininteligible] para pasar a la chambre a gas, fillos y padres. No podían más resistir la sufriencia y la hambrera y el piojo, ni el trabajo y se iban voluntarios a la chambre a gas.
David Boder: Bueno, dígame...eh...¿qué es que dijo usted de los...?
David Lea: ¿De la esterilización?
David Boder: Bueno, sí.
David Lea: En el campo de Auschwitz, que es la misma dirección que el campo de Birkenau, es unos veinte minutos a pie, esterilizaban a las mujeres de 18 años y hasta 27 años. Las esterilizaban en el Bloco 10 de Auschwitz. En Berkinau, esterilizaban de 22 años fita 30 años a los jóvenes, en el Bloco...
David Boder: ¿A los hombres?
David Lea: Hombres, hombres.
David Boder: ¿Cómo los esterilizaban?
David Lea: Los llevaban allí y con inyecciones, los esterilizaban. Con inyecciones los esterilizaban. Al Bloco 26. Esto paso al Juin, al 4, 7, 8 de Juin.
David Boder: ¿Qué mes?
David Lea: Juin
David Boder: Mes de junio
David Lea: Junio. Sí. De 1943. Después que hacían esto, que esterilizaban a mujeres y hombres, se echaban los SS, había unas chambres especialitas para los hombres, los jóvenes y las mujeres en edad, se echaban ahí juntos...si querían tener los doctores de las SS...si podían prevenir a realizar otra raza. Y la más parte, no parirían. La más parte, el 95% no parirían.
David Boder: Bueno. Los otros...que...¿se pusieron embarazadas? ¿o cómo? Eh...¿Qué quiere decir 95% no podían...eh no...?
David Lea: Los 95% no volvían, a poder, a quitar los espermas.
David Boder: Oh. No podían volver a tener acto sexual.
David Lea: No podían tener el acto sexual.
David Boder: Bueno. Entonces, metieron juntos los hombres con las mujeres.
David Lea: Juntos con las mujeres y no podían hacer nada. Mas a notar que les daban buena comida a estos hombres para ver si podían hacer cosas, mas normalmente mesmo que les dieran toda la comida del mundo era imposible de arribar porque estaban bien esterilizados.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Y cada día, en el campo de Birkenau había una selección de hombres, de 2000 a 3000 hombres quemaban cada noche, deportados que estaban en el campo [ininteligible] tres meses o cinco meses o un año. Como [ininteligible] judíos, como judíos sefaradí, como judíos lituanos, como hungareses y los llevaban al crematorio.
David Boder: Dígame otra vez el caso cuando pidieron permiso...permiso de rezar sobre los muertos.
David Lea: ¿Sobre?
David Boder: Que dijo usted que los que quemaron a los muertos pidieron permiso que podían rezar, que podían...eh...Dijo usted anteriormente que no les permitían de decir sus...
David Lea: Ah, sí. Me topé en Landberg, al 45 en Baviera. Trabajaba en un comando de quince hombres judíos y yo, dieciséis.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Un día, de los comandos que trabajaba, murió la hermana en el campo de concentración número 7. Naturalmente, nosotros como judíos, llamemos un joven que tenía un amigo, un compañero, para [ininteligible] a excavar.
David Boder: [El entrevistador dice la palabra excavar en otro idioma para ver si comprendió].
David Lea: [El entrevistado confirma lo entendido por el entrevistador]. Y entonces, cuando hicimos la excavación, el SS viene y nos dice “¿qué están haciendo sucios judíos con un libro?”. Le dice el hombre...
David Boder: Ah, ¿tenían un libro?
David Lea: Sí. Teníamos un libro...los hungareses y los poloneses judíos...cuando los hungareses al 44 que los deportaron, traían libros [ininteligible] y [ininteligible]. Y nosotros guardábamos en la tierra, en los pantalones, guardábamos los libros de la ley para [ininteligible].
David Boder: Para rezar.
David Lea: Para rezar. Cuando le ve, dice...di...dice “¿qué es ese sucio libro que tienes judío?”, pero me dice a mí...
David Boder: Hable más despacio.
David Lea: “¿Qué es ese sucio libro que tienes?”. Mi compañero se alzó y le dijo que “es mi hermana y quería rezar”. Y dice “para los sucios no necesita [ininteligible]”. Tomó la pala, levantó la pala y le dio en la cabeza y el hombre, al momento murió. Y nosotros lo enterramos con la hermana, con 400 más en una fora. En cada fora que hacíamos, 300, 350, 400, 450. Después de dos metros y cuarenta centímetros de hondura, echábamos la tierra y antes de cubrirlos echábamos [ininteligible] o cal para que no diera [ininteligible]
David Boder: ¿Para que no diera qué?
David Lea: [ininteligible]
David Boder: Ah.
David Lea: Y entonces, echábamos piedra y tierra, y enterrábamos la fosa y nos íbamos. Al otro día, hacíamos el mismo trabajo, porque era un campo de cuarentena. Era un campo para matar con las inyecciones a los judíos. Las inyecciones que echábamos, mesmo en el brazo, mesmo en el pie, después de tres a cuatro minutos, la sangre le subía a [ininteligible]
David Boder: ¿A dónde?
David Lea: Cuando echaba la inyección, la sangre le subía [ininteligible], ya estaba preto
David Boder: ¿Quiénes echaban las inyecciones? ¿Ustedes?
David Lea: No. Los SS.
David Boder: Los SS.
David Lea: Y en muchos campos, los SS daban orden a los judíos que echaran inyecciones, pero los judíos obligatoriamente lo hacían porque si no lo hacían, el SS estaba con la metralleta y ya estaba detrás de él y “si no haces esto te mato”.
David Boder: ¿Y?
David Lea: Y claro, el judío que era venir, le echaban la inyección.
David Boder: Pero dígame. ¿De dónde la sangre aparecía?
David Lea: En la [ininteligible]
David Boder: Aquí en el...
David Lea: Y preto y aquí.
David Boder: ¿Parecía salir?
David Lea: No. Se veía todo preto, el meollo de la [ininteligible] se hacía preta con dos puntos, tres puntos y ya...al momento se morían. Mas después de dos a tres puntos,...
David Boder: ¿Quiénes hacían los tres puntos?
David Lea: Tres minutos
David Boder: ¿Tres minutos?
David Lea: De dos a tres minutos, después se hacía todo preto. El [ininteligible] preto. Y nosotros los tomábamos y los echábamos en una [ininteligible] y los enterrábamos. Después, en el campo 1 en Landberg, había el grande SS medical. El nombre era Blanca, tenía nombre español, un alto, moreno. Era como yo de grande.
David Boder: ¿Una mujer?
David Lea: No. Un hombre. Se llamaba Blanca. Un alto moreno, alrededor de 35 a 34 años. Este no podía ver a los judíos, mesmo a los judíos querían trabajar, que estaban en buena salud, unos cuantos, él ordenaba echarles inyecciones. Este fue matado, este mismo, tenía una criatura y una mujer. Fue...se mató
David Boder: ¿Cómo una criatura?
David Lea: Un pequeño.
David Boder: Ajá. ¿Un niño?
David Lea: Un niño. Un pequeño. Tenía un pequeño y una mujer con él.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Cuando los americanos se estaban acercando del Lager 1, él ya vio que se estaban acercando, no tenía más para hacer, nada para salvar...tomó al pequeño, lo mandó a la [ininteligible], tomó una inyección, mató [ininteligible] a la mujer suya en primero, después [ininteligible] y él. Y un compañero mío que se topa actualmente en París le quitó la hora y el anillo de la mano y...cuando vio que 2ya estaba muerto, le quitó el anillo y la hora de la mano.
David Boder: ¿Cómo se llama la hora? ¿El reloj?
David Lea: El reloj. La hora y el anillo. Este camarado se topa actualmente en París y nos vemos cada día y cada noche.
David Boder: Bueno
David Lea: Quería...
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: En el campo 5, en el campo 5, después de la ocupación,
David Boder: ¿El campo 5 de qué?
David Lea: El campo 5 de Landsberg, Baviera, después de la ocupación, estábamos trabajando en unos comandos muy duros de árboles, para cortar árboles, para [ininteligible] nosotros, no podíamos hacer trabajo porque no teníamos comida y diríamos “si quieres que trabajemos, danos comida”, sino no [ininteligible] necesidad. No podemos trabajar 14 horas en el día, matándonos es mejor. Los SS no nos querían matar.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: No nos querían matar. Los vamos a hacer penar, los vamos a maltratar de leña y después los vamos a matar cuando nos place y nos gusta a nosotros. Esto aconteció en el Lager de Landsberg. En el Lager 5, en el Lager 6, en el Lager 7, en el Lager 8, en el Lager 9, en el Lager 10 y en el Lager 11. Laborábamos a la estación [ininteligible], ese era el comando
David Boder: ¿[Ininteligible]? [El entrevistador confirma el nombre del comando en alemán]
David Lea: [Ininteligible. El entrevistado repite el nombre del comando en alemán]. Yo laboraba al Lager 7 al Tot comando. El nombre mío...
David Boder: ¿Tot comando?
David Lea: Tot comando, sí.
David Boder: That was bad. ¿Qué era esto?
David Lea: Tot comando era un comando especialista para enterrar los muertos, porque en Alemania era prohibido de hacer crematorios y de quemar a los muertos, porque la más parte de la población civil alemana ignoraba que había crematorios y fornos. Muchas veces veníamos de...nos encontrábamos con civiles alemanes y les explicábamos. Y los civiles decían: “esa barbaridad, el pueblo alemán no la hace nunca”. Pero nosotros, les dijimos: que un día, nosotros ya sabemos que [ininteligible] los alemanes, mas va a saber la historia, o [ininteligible], o mesmo [ininteligible], que existió crematorios en Alemania”.
David Lea: El más lungo y cruel crematorio fue en el campo de Buchenwald, el cual tengo un compañero que dormimos todos juntos en el [ininteligible] en la Maison de la Rue [ininteligible]. 9 Rue [ininteligible], París. Somos 4 de ellos, 4 judíos. Los tres son del campo de Buchenwald, el uno es del campo de Dachau [ininteligible]. Uno se llama [ininteligible], el otro se llama Henry Suchami, actualmente labora en la American [ininteligible]. Henry Suchami es el primer transporte sefardí de Grecia en Auschwitz. 109957, el número [ininteligible] 109957 primo transporte de Grecia, el cual perdió padre, madre, familia, tres criaturas de cinco años, de siete años y de once años, y mujer. Y la mujer, preñada.
David Lea: [Nombre ininteligible], un joven de alrededor de 35 años, perdió una criatura y su mujer. Y está escrito a la migración palestiniana y no hay posibilidad de partir, no hay inda posibilidad de partir. El [ininteligible] palestiniano de París, que se topa en la calle 83 Avenue [ininteligible], le dice “mañana, después de mañana, de aquí a cinco meses, de aquí a un mes, de aquí a tres meses, te vas a ir”. Este joven tiene parientes en Palestina, mas como es flaco, no puede irse ilegal, se espanta, se está quedando conmigo...
David Boder: Es que es flaco...
David Lea: Del campo [ininteligible]. Como está [ininteligible] el campo, [ininteligible] ni trabajar puede, ni nada. Naturalmente, es que espera de mí, un compañero que estuvimos al campo tres años, un bocado de pan o una calza que le va a dar una [ininteligible] para él se meter. Si no le da una calza, un calzado, no tiene para meter, que...y no puede trabajar. Tiene flaco, tiene [ininteligible] los pulmones. No es sólo este caso de los déportés, hay muchos déportés aquí en Francia, el cual...
David Boder: Por supuesto.
David Lea: Hay muchos déportés aquí en Francia, que estamos sufriendo ainda. Mesmo que nos queremos ir en Palestina y estamos viendo la barbarie del inglés, que si nosotros...la juventud que salimos de los campos, si nos vamos en Palestina, nunca empezaríamos a trabajar. Yo, lebanés que le estoy hablando, no pensaría nunca a trabajar en Palestina, pensaría en tomar el fusil o la metralleta y demandar la libertad. Si no la toma la libertad con la guerra...si no tengo la libertad con la política, la va a tomar con la guerra. Nunca pensaría a trabajar. Si me muero en Palestina, algún día mis hijos o mis hermanos van a venir. Porque ya vi el campo cuando estuve tres años, ya vi la exterminación de 6000 judíos y no me gustaría nunca esta política inglesa. Nosotros, los rescatés de los campos, queremos ir presto a batirnos contra esos...sucia raz...sucia política inglesa y no tenemos la posibilidad por esto de donde estamos. Que nos topamos en Fra...actualmente en Francia muchos jóvenes judíos y que están migrando ilegal.
David Boder: Emigrando a Francia
David Lea: No. Está emigrando a la Palestina.
David Boder: Sí.
David Lea: Y un día la Palestina...un día, la Palestina la tomaremos y mesmo si se morirían 50.000 judíos en Palestina en combate o 100.000 judíos. No es lo importante.
David Boder: [In English] This ends Spool 42 of Mr. David Lea.